you are a pisces saturn you are a pisces
mars you are a pisces chiron you are a
pisces juno and you are a pisces moon i
want to hear a little a little about me
i know a little bit it seems like you
know a lot about astrology my aunt's an
astrologist really are we rolling
they're always rolling
hello welcome back to another episode of
horoscope it out my name is elisa kelly
and i am in
a sandwich so you are a taurus son
and you were born at 1 pm so your sun is
very close to what's called your mid
heaven so the very top of the sky
in that same theme that we were talking
about of legacy how you're going to be
remembered so to have your son next to
your midheaven very much says i'm going
to be remembered for who i am my
presence my identity my individuality is
going to be sort of what
message i leave behind you have a leo
rising
and your rising sign is how you perceive
the world so this shows that and these
are actually square each other so this
shows that there is this really
interesting
connection between
your perception of reality sort of
seeing reality as larger than life as
something where it's there's tons of
opportunities how are you going to seize
them how are you going to take advantage
of these wonderful moments and your son
your sense of self being well i'm gonna
have to put myself out there in order to
do that and recognizing that you know in
order for you to be able to achieve the
things that you want to achieve it's
almost like about find tapping into that
humility of being like well here we go
let's just do it i'll put on whatever i
need to put on and just get the thing
done get on this grey bun
i'll put on this gray wig
and make my fortune
your pisces moon which is what's going
on on the inside is really sensitive
it's really um empathetic and it's
absorbing information constantly so you
are very strong and you present as
someone who's very fierce and someone
who's not gonna settle and i'm not gonna
you know take no for an answer but on
the inside there's a whole internal
dialogue that is not always being
reflected externally interesting so the
connection here is that because you have
so much pisces in your chart
you can speak to this moon in pisces
really just by being who you are
existing as you exist and being open and
being caring and being receptive so you
feel protected and safe because you know
that your that internal narrative that
isn't always something that you want to
be broadcasting is being seen and
appreciated so this is going to be a
year of lots of big transformation for
you the where jupiter is flowing into
your chart is it's moving from
the area associated with partnership
into the area associated with
metamorphosis you're going to feel the
shift internally as opposed to
externally first this is going to be
something that does require that sort of
compromise and you say okay well in
order for me to you know get to where i
want to go in whatever way i want to get
there i'm going to need to make certain
decisions endorse this diarrhea drug yes
potentially but it'll you know four
million dollars is four million
four million is four million
well this actually is the this part of
this eighth house is uh other people's
money
oh okay yeah it's the scorpio area which
has to do with all of the things that we
purge what you're gonna get a diarrhea
campaign is the score
the scorpio is the
[Laughter]
i never thought i was gonna have to say
that on camera i mean i know i knew
about the taurus voice thing because i
sing but that's oh i heard pisces have
ugly feet and someone just beautiful
feet okay someone just told me in the
dog park today that
maybe it was a jealous person it sounds
like
everything i found out that my
neighbor's also pisces she's like we
have really ugly feet she hasn't seen
mine but maybe she might have some kind
of shadowed she has a shadowed
relationship with her own feet well i
don't know pisces does rule the feet
they what does that mean there's an
association between different zodiac
signs and different body parts so yes
and pisces is the feat ladies questions
thoughts concerns may we have your card
absolutely
[Laughter]
[Music]